[Music]
it'd be a better human Muse submitted by
I love oh I love come on tiger yeah
that's what happens there's more
important Georgie irrelevant nothing
anymore
waitis thunderously I said you was Tiger
Hasina are you when you're the one
amazing that is true though oh [ __ ]
oh let them know you're you're like the
maid now that's what you need so happy
to like have it back so I made Morton
again a writer for life hackers suggest
to not blame others for mistakes if you
refused to help them learn oh that may
do you guys do like life advice on JK
news every so often to every so often
every solving our whole channel is made
for life advice yeah I mean well you
guys are so wise that's out David makes
his living not really Hawaii so explain
to us what's what's what's the deal with
this so on this website called life
hacker life they have these midweek
meditations and so in this one this
writer he was planning on a quote from
Marcus Aurelius really really or LS m /
yes are also brilliant aka Russell Crowe
yeah so what he said is quote if he is
going wrong
teach him kindly and show him what he
has failed to see you boy was a prisoner
if you can't do that blame yourself or
perhaps not even yourself and another
version is if someone is slipping up
kindly correct them and point out what
they missed but if you can't blame
yourself
or blame no one true them so it's like
if you witness their idiocy you're just
as much to blame for not saying
something or stopping them people do
that [ __ ] all the time they just watched
somebody fail and then behind their back
to be like oh did you see that
[ __ ] over there he's
entertaining people loved watching the
train wreck
what do you think they mean no I like in
his thing if he's like if someone failed
instead of going haha what and he did he
felt it's like hey maybe you can do this
that next
you're successful what's also like maybe
not making fun of them but getting mad
at them like why did you do that yeah
yeah yeah when you saw why but you can't
tell them or you just shut your mouth
and you don't feel anything or say
anything it's one or the other mmm and
in both instances if you see the
wronging and you don't try to write it
then you are also wrong yeah oh it's
like somebody is getting butt-fucked in
public but you just let it happen
or even laughs no it's basically if you
have an incompetent employee and you're
just pissed at them for being
incompetent instead of showing them how
to [ __ ] be right this is good
managerial skills which a lot of people
do I think it's good social
responsibility school students I think
what they're also saying is like if if
someone like like let's say cuts a
couple lanes or doesn't merge correctly
instead of being the usual road rage
Mike you can go up to my hey such no
you're supposed to turn on your signal
see that's what I'm trying to see that's
like me it's like how come I don't grow
my channel and do more because if I do
it gives me more work so I I just choose
not to things that you can't okay when
you're aware of the problem and you
don't do anything exactly but this is
about other people but you can be the
other people to other people frustrating
you but you can be frustrated yourself
too Oh what's the point that they're
trying to make that like oh that's it
there's nothing else to the article oh
there's what it means well yeah okay
what it means they have here it says
people make mistakes when they do make a
mistake and you feel the need to point
it out at least do them the kindness of
showing them how to avoid it next time
you put their face in the pee yeah white
fingers and refuse to teach the blame is
on you the whole point or you could just
cut that person out of your life
completely you know had that prophet all
here is this bliss because that's what I
do
yeah it's like oh I could fix that but I
could just delete them out my life but
what if they're a good friend oh oh and
you're loud I'll have good friends like
that that's a good thing he just
complimented us wait what doesn't have
good
no because I was about to make fun of
myself stupid you [ __ ] cut it to my
joke well you ready make you [ __ ]
some of the stupid that sweater so
stupid
yeah what the duck man conversation with
a [ __ ] guys Donald Duck doesn't wear
pants but when he comes out of the
shower he wears a towel that's right
what am i on
that's very interesting yeah the cutest
button maybe when the feathers get wet
the Daniell a name that isn't a duck's
dick really weird supposed to be real
with a spiral
- I think pig - okay have you seen the
turtles dick oh my god it looks like an
alien Bernal Doug
it's like slimy and just vain I don't
even know it's like shape weird it's
like it's like splatters out yeah you
know like those things you get out of
like the kid vending machines that's
like it's a hand it's like that you
could buy one for 25 cents anyway I know
I don't go to a supermarket where
suppose you you know the thing is this
is true but it takes so much like mental
power to just teach and tell people
there's a patience I think it's yeah
that's that's mental power yes an
emotional strength all that [ __ ] I just
rather man [ __ ] we just want people to
read our [ __ ] minds dude just do the
work for me and I don't want to yell
that and then also because how many
people want to send people come come on
are like IG or YouTube and they're
trying that's what they're doing but
then they come off and it's like so
offensive and you're like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know yeah there's like there's
another part of like there's a there
should be an article attached to this
which is like how do you do this in the
right way because some people if you
don't just use criticism and they're
like the wall up or they'll be like uh
like [ __ ] you exactly I'm out but like
if you're actually are trying to help
them like there's a way to do that that
not a lot of people have attacked see
this is Western philosophy Asian
philosophy is just you [ __ ] up let
be know I'll be like parents will just
[ __ ] feature yeah like with the
stranger right what do you yeah is you
don't control that's none of your
business
if dad this was you learn you'll learn
on his own if the Chang family wants to
be stupid that'll be stupid yeah you
don't learn on their own like I don't
know I always appreciate it when ever
you guys point out my missteps and like
things that I think that I love it it's
fantastic anything wrong don't listen to
them you're perfect um no but I'd like
to work for your company man it's mostly
[ __ ] gross he's doing this he's like
if I'm making a mistake and you don't
point it out cuz you like it oh yeah oh
yeah you seem nice over there though no
because I always get [ __ ] from everybody
no none of their walls have holes I know
you guys are not going to get your
security deposit back about the future
like what the [ __ ] that's why we're not
moving out of this [ __ ] cuz I'm not I
don't care
nice let them move I don't want to move
out you know how much of the pay I don't
want to pay security deposit I'd rather
pay every month and pay security deposit
I don't like this place I bet you
there's no abuse that Wong foo is there
that we don't know about
well he's not gonna admit it unless he's
no we're fine it's great do you yell at
your employee we don't we have important
discussions yes cuz we do all the time
that's this healthy yeah you know it's
great that you guys can yell and still
be friends and you know get in a room
you've never yelled at me oh man
sometimes though just for fun I want to
be that guy dude for no reason you know
what it is you guys have weapons at your
office so no one wants to cross you guys
people cross you know cuz I don't have
guns I don't have them I'm not gonna use
it for bad it's to protect everybody I
wonder if there's a country where you
could literally slap your employees
tomorrow yeah it's not like half the
Asian countries oh that's why I'm sorry
all the Asian country
from the 80s and 90s lit everyone just
got smacked in the back of the head if
you would know right that's right yeah I
see it
well Korea they're getting a lot more
savvy with it now you can't you can't
just go around slap the [ __ ] out of
people with a pen yeah oh I can just do
this move out the way
Wow well I don't know how it for you
guys like you guys are all bosses
everyone here except me I think it's
easier when you're talking about
business because there's a
responsibility there's a clear goal is a
clear if someone in your queue rectly
failed if someone in your team isn't
doing well then the whole team
yes poorly yeah when I'm viewing this on
a social level that's the hard part
I really think about what about
relationships when you have a
boyfriend/girlfriend where it's like hey
you're not actually doing that right
oh that's a good that one I don't hold
my mouth you do or don't don't I don't I
let go but the things that I do feel
like I like look for example like I'm an
avid lifter right and if I go to like a
commercial gym or something I see
someone lifting wrong yeah I go am an
Ashes but uh yeah and I probably should
say something yeah but then that's when
I'm like I'm [ __ ] lazy or [ __ ] this
Bowlers it's only when you frustrates
you yeah right cuz that doesn't affect
you it does frustrate me though does yes
I never want to work out with Bart oh he
would just be angry the whole time well
like for example it well frustrates me
more isn't the person that's in
experienced it be if there's an
inexperienced person and that person has
a personal trainer and the personal
trainer is not doing oh yeah
they're putting their trust in that then
I want to go in and roast the [ __ ] out
of the personal trainer you should you
should work out with Bart he's actually
very very friendly but he pays too much
attention to you uh if you try to slack
off he'll basically call you a puss on
only if you're one of those guys that's
like 1 2 7 13 give me that much
attention he just gives me a program and
I look at Joe okay that is well he's out
of before I
didn't do that but what he does do is
between like exercises he's like this
like just that's not that's not the
posture that heart stopped so I need it
to go again miss Wulla literally
squatting like 420 pounds and I'm just
like chillin in a corner he just goes
let's go he'll leave the gym and they'll
heal a point around a person Jim hey
watch it
who are you
you should feel lucky he's focusing so
much on you that's expensive that ya
personal trainer from Bart yeah we don't
get that we just get a program yeah
that's all yes I don't like it
[Music]